what the federal authorities are  very very confident it was the our evil  group  which is it's not state affiliated with  russia so  you know they don't believe it's the  russian quote-unquote government  or the intelligence agencies it's a it's  a  worldwide um hacker affiliate or hacker  associate if you will  that has people all around the world  believe me when i tell you we are all  over  the 40 or so service providers and the  50 customers or so that have been  impacted  all over me trying to help and do  everything but for those that aren't  it's scary for them because it's the  unknown technology  i.t i think is a net positive in the  world i think we'd all agree with that  it allows  you know supply chain it allows our  modern society  as long as we want to keep a modern  society i'm not being dramatic i mean if  we want to keep  electricity running if we want to keep  um  you know people want to be able to use  amazon all that kind of stuff  this is this is the new world